القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تعلن عن منع مرور
السفن المتجهه الى الكيان الصهيوني من اي
جنسيه كانت اذا لم يدخل لقطاع غزه حاجته
من الغذاء والدواء وستصبح هدفا مشروعا
لقواتنا المسلحه بمل
بم
بلخ
مصر تحذر الولايات المتحده وتل ابيب ليعلن
البيت الابيض لا فرصه لهدني في القطاع
اجراءات امريكيه ضد المستوطنين العبريين
رفض روسي لخطه عبريه ضد سكان القطاع ضربات
الجيش العبري تنهي بعضا من الاسرى
العبريين والفصائل ترد اتفاق روسي تركي
شان الغاز في اوروبا واشنطن تحول اموال
اوكرانيا الى الداخل الامريكي فضيحه لوزير
الدفاع الامريكي في الكونجرس الخارجيه
البريطانيه نحن نعرف بوتين والروس تهديد
لامن اوروبا وامريكا والمخابرات الامريكيه
واشنطن طورت استراتيجيه خاسره لهجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد مصر تقول
كلمتها هي كلمه ولن تتكرر يقولها المصريون
على الدوام وها هو موقع سيوس يفيد بان مصر
حذرت الولايات المتحده وتل ابيب من نشوء
قطيعه في العلاقات اذا تم تاجير
الفلسطينيين الى سيناء وحسب اكسيوس فان
سبب اهميه ذلك هو ان العلاقات الوثيقه بين
مصر وتل ابيب وخاصه بين الجيش واجهزه
المخابرات كانت ذات اهميه بالغه في عده
مراحل من الحرب فيما يتعلق بالافراج عن
الرهائن هناك اعربت الفصائل عن تقديرها
للموقف المصري والاردني والمواقف العربيه
والاسلاميه والدوليه الرافضه لمؤامره
تهجير سكان القطاع ودعت لرفضها والتصدي
لها لتدخل روسيا على الخط وعلى لسان نائب
المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس الامن الدولي
دميتري بوليانسكي الذي اكد ان روسيا ترفض
اي مخططات لتهجير سكان القطاع الى جنوبه
معتبرا ذلك بمثابه نكبه جديده للشعب
الفلسطيني من جانبه قال منسق الاتصالات في
البيت الابيض جون كيربي انلا فرصه ادنه
قريبه في القطاع مضيفا لسنا قريبين من
اتفاق اخر بشان وقف اطلاق النار في القطاع
ولسنا قريبين من الوصول الى هدنه انسانيه
جديده فيما اعلنت الخدمه الصحفيه في البيت
الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اكد
في اتصال هاتفي مع رئيس الوزراء العبري
نتنياهو على ضروره انشاء ممرات انسانيه في
القطاع ذا واعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن ان السلطات الامريكيه
مستعده لاتخاذ باجراءات جديده ضد
المستوطنين العبريين في الضفه الغربيه
للحد من العنف ضد المدنيين بدوره صرح
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو وتريش
بان عواقب ما يحدث في القطاع ستكون مدمره
على المنطقه باكملها مشددا على ان الامور
وصلت الى نقطه الانهيار ميدانيا تواصل
القصف المدفعي العبري والقاء عشرات
القنابل الدخانيه والفسفور الابيض على
مخيم الجبال يا شمالي القطاع بما اكدت
فصائل اشتباكها مع جنود الجيش العبري
وايقاع خسائر في صفوفه لتقتحم قوات تل ابي
مخيم الفارع جنوب طوباس وسط اشتباكات
عنيفه وتحاصر عددا من البنايات في رام
الله وتصادر 23 سياره في بلده بيت امر
جنوبي الخليل في المقابل اعلنت الفصائل
اطلاق دفعات صاروخيه مكثفه على تلبيب
الكبرى وذكر مصدر امني عبري ان الصواريخ
اطلقت من جباليه وال الشجاعيه شمال القطاع
قالت الشرطه العبريه انها تقوم بعمليات
تمشيط في مواقع عده في تل ابيب بحثا عن
شضايا صواريخ اطلقت من القطاع وتم
اعتراضها خلال المعارك اعلنت الفصائل عن
مقتل واصابه عدد من الاسرى العبريين لديها
بسبب القصف العبري المستمر على جميع انحاء
القطاع من جانبها اعلنت مقاومه لبنان
استهداف مواقع عبريه عده بمحاذاه الجنوب
اللبناني مؤكده تحقيق اصابات مباشره تح
تالف روسي تركي انقره وموسكو في مركب واحد
والعين ترمق القاره الاوروبيه ليصرح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بانه اتفق
مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حول مساله
امدادات الغاز الروسي الى منطقه البلقان
واوروبا عبر مشروع مركز الغاز في تركيا
بشان اوكرانيا افاد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن بان 90% من اجمالي
حجم المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا تم وجهها الى المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الامريكي ما يضمن النمو الاقتصادي
ليخرج وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ديفيد
كامرون مصرحا لقناه سكاي نيوز ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لن يتوقف عند
اوكرانيا اذا لم يتم وقفه هناك مضيفا ان
رسالته تتمثل في ان تهديد الامن الاوروبي
هو ايضا تهديد للامن الامريكي وقال نحن
نعرف بوتين اذا لم نوقفه الان فسوف يعود
للحصول على المز
فيما كان ضابط وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه السابق لاري جونسون قد صرح بان
امريكا طورت استراتيجيه خاسره للهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني واوضح ان الغرب كان يعلم
مسبقا ان العمليات الهجوميه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لم يكن لها اي فرصه للنجاح هنا
كشف الصحفي الامريكي تاكور كارلسون ان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودد اوستن هدد
اعضاء الكونجرس بارسال اقربائهم للمشاركه
في نزاع اوكرانيا في حال احجامهم عن تقديم
المساعده مجددا لكييف في فضيحه غير مسبوقه
داخل الكونجرس الامريكي في روسيا افاد
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديمتري سكوف
بان التصريحات الامريكيه بان روسيا ستذهب
الى المفاوضات مع اوكرانيا بشروط كيف غير
واقعيه اما في اوكرانيا فاعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه القضاء على اكثر من
4900 عسكري اوكراني واسقاط خمس مقاتله
ومروح و4 2 مسيره اوكرانيه اطلقتها قوات
كيف على مختلف المحاور خلال
اسبوع اصابت
[موسيقى]
كدن
ه